hey Vsauce Michael here down here but
which way is down and how much does down
way well down raise about a hundredth of
a gram per cubic centimeter it is light
and airy which makes it a great source
of insulation and buoyancy for water
birds but if you let go of down it falls
down
so that's which way down is it's the
direction gravity is pulling everything
in now for someone on the other side of
the earth my down is their up but where
are falling things going why do things
fall
are they being pushed or pulled or is it
because of time travel first things
first let's turn the Sun into a black
hole we can do that using universe
sandbox 2 this simulator will blow your
mind I love it in fact I love it so much
I put a code to keep the game for free
in the current curiosity box if you're
not subscribed to the box yet you are
missing out okay look for the purposes
of this video we want the solar system
and here it is notice that everything's
moving pretty quickly around the Sun
that's because we currently have the
game set so that every second that
passes for us is 14 days almost in the
game if I change this to one second
we're looking at the solar system in
real time you'll notice that it almost
looks like it's frozen even though the
earth is traveling around the Sun at
about thirty kilometers per second it
barely appears to be moving that is how
vast space is anyway let's go back to 14
days I like that motion now look at the
Sun it is not currently a black hole but
we can change that what we need to do is
compress the Sun so let's lock its mass
so that it doesn't change while we make
its radius smaller
let's make its radius as small as we can
and oh where to go what's still there
it's just become a black hole pretty
spooky but now let's look at the rest of
the solar system all right
zooming out and huh nothing's changed I
mean something's changed it's colder and
darker but nothing's flying off into
space or getting sucked in you see by
shrinking the Sun we didn't change the
direction of down for the planets
they're always being pulled by gravity
towards its middle and making it smaller
didn't move where the middle was but
also the strength of that force pulling
them to the middle of the Sun stayed the
same that gives us a clue as to what
down is the clue is the other thing we
didn't change mass mass is a measure of
how hard it is to accelerate something
to change its motion now right now these
two balls have zero motion relative to
me slapping around this hollow plastic
ball is pretty easy but doing the same
to this solid steel ball there's a lot
harder now gravity and weight have
nothing to do with this
gravity acts downward not against my
horizontal slapping of course gravity
does contribute to friction but friction
works against me when I start moving the
ball but works with me when I stop the
ball and the steel ball is harder to
stop than the plastic ball the
difference is mass the steel ball is
more massive it's more resistant to
having its motion changed mass is an
intrinsic property it does not depend on
what's around or change from place to
place it can sometimes be thought of as
the amount of matter
something has your mass is the same
regardless of where you are on the moon
on earth in the middle of intergalactic
space floating around but all of this
said mass does seem to care about what's
around mass loves company
things with mass and/or energy are
attracted together by a force that we
call gravity the feeling of gravity is
just you and the earth being attracted
to one another now every portion of an
object with mass attracts other portions
towards it the average of all this
pulling is an attraction between centers
of mass giant things like Earth exert an
obvious pull but everything does even a
baseball these two baseballs are
attracted together by their own gravity
z' except their masses are so small the
forces minuscule and it can't overcome
friction or push air out of the way
they're never gonna come together but if
you put two baseball's one meter apart
in the middle of empty space where no
other forces could act on them they
would literally fall together and
collide it would take three days to
happen but it would Isaac Newton found
that the strength of the force bringing
two things together is equal to the
product of their masses divided by the
distance between their centers of mass
squared times big G the gravitational
constant if you make one of two objects
more massive or move them closer
together the force will be stronger and
this force of attraction is what we call
weight so mass is intrinsic whereas
weight depends on what's around
now a weird thing happens when you weigh
yourself on most scales weight is a
force but scales display pounds or
kilograms which are units of mass what's
going on is that a scale is activated by
a force any force it doesn't have to be
caused by gravity the scale then
displays what amount of mass near the
surface of the earth would be attracted
to the earth with the force it's
detecting now since scales tend to be
used on the surface of the earth by
people on which the only force acting is
gravity they tend to not be very far off
but they can be easily tricked and they
further lead to the confusion between
mass and weight
notice that weight is mutual you are
pulled down by earth with the same force
that you pull up on earth according to a
scale I weigh 180 pounds on earth
[Music]
and the earth weighs 180 pounds on me
but because the Earth's mass is so much
greater than my own
and because the more massive something
is the more it resists being moved our
equal and opposite weight forces
accelerate me a lot more than the earth
if you drop a pencil from a height of 6
feet the pencil doesn't just fall to the
earth more precisely they both come
together they're attracted to each other
by equal forces but the same force moves
the pencil a lot more than the earth
when you let go of the pencil the earth
is literally pulled up to the pencil by
the pencils own gravity a distance equal
to about 9 trillion the width of a
proton that same force moves the pencil
the remaining distance which is still
pretty much 6 feet at the height of the
International Space Station's orbit you
and Earth are attracted about 10% less
than when you're on the surface about
8.8 times your mass but not zero for
this reason weightless astronauts in
zero-gravity are neither weightless nor
in zero gravity their weight force fails
to bring them and earth together because
they move horizontally so quickly that
they fall just as fast as Earth's
surface curves away from them and even
though they're experiencing 90% of the
gravity you and I are feeling right now
that's why they don't just fly away
there are no forces called g-forces to
resist their weight since everything
around them is falling to its resistance
to your weight force stress deformation
that is needed for you to feel weight
what astronauts in orbit actually lack
is apparent weight likewise a helium
balloon has weight I mean it's made out
of matter it clearly has mass so it's
attracted to the
earth let's try to measure its weight
force that's a-ok it has negative
apparent weight that's because it's
attraction to the earth is weaker than
the buoyant forces from the air around
it that push it up now while it moves up
it pushes air molecules down but they
transfer that force widely not just
directly down onto the scale
buoyant forces are caused by the fact
that whenever you are immersed in a
fluid like water or air molecules
lowered down are at greater pressure
that are being pressed by the weight of
all the molecules above them and are
closer to earth so they're pulled to it
with a stronger force now having greater
pressure means they pack a bigger punch
when they collide with things so
horizontally those collisions cancel out
but vertically the stronger collisions
from below went out providing lift a
buoyant force
now this even happens on your own body
across its surface area air lifts you
with a force of about one Newton which
is equal to the weight force of an apple
so if you weighed yourself in a vacuum
you would weigh about this much more but
that's not all Earth's spin causes it to
bulge at the equator so the closer you
are to it the further you are from
Earth's center of mass and the less your
actual gravitational weight will be down
is always changing I mean where is
Earth's center of mass it would always
be the same as Earth's geometric middle
if Earth's composition was uniform but
earth contains pockets of massive rock
at different depths water mountains it's
got moving changing insides and air and
seasonal ice and though they're far away
gravity extends forever from everything
so the moon the Sun the planets all of
them pull on you negligibly but truly
you weigh about a millionth of your
weight less when the moon is directly
above you this chunky shifting balance
of material on earth and ever
where else in the universe means that
down is always changing on top of that
Earth's spin skews what you consider the
direction of down away from its center
of mass because the push you get from
Earth's spin seems to slightly lift you
reducing your apparent weight and
bending down towards the equator the net
result is an apparent weight reduction
at the equator of about half of a
percent if a scale guesses your mass
must be 200 pounds at the poles
it'll guess that you're 199 at the
equator the 9.8 multiplier used so often
in physics is calculated based on how
these factors affect someone at 45
degrees latitude all of these influences
on the direction of down result in a
total vertical deflection that's only
ever at most a few arc seconds anywhere
on earth that's not enough to be felt
but changes in direction and strength
can be used to study the shape of the
seafloor determine what's under you or
even help you discover ancient buried
rooms point is all of our downs aren't a
bunch of radially symmetric lines down
is an uncombed mess now since solids
don't flow they can have shapes that
don't pay much mind to this but water
can flow so ignoring influences like
wind and tides the surface of oceans and
lakes and puddles is always
perpendicular to down if water could
pass through land or if earth were
submerged in water gravity would be the
same everywhere along its bumpy surface
such a surface is called a geoid and can
be drawn at any altitude if you wanted
to build a table that completely
enclosed the earth it would have to have
rolling undulation z' nearly 100 meters
at some points in order to be level so
that a ball placed anywhere on it
wouldn't roll here is Earth's goe
exaggerated a thousand times you'd weigh
about a hundredth of a percent less a
few grams here than you would say here
where gravity is a bit stronger point is
the strength and direction
down is variable by location and changes
over time so down is a fluctuating
vector easy enough except why should
matter attract matter in the first place
Isaac Newton was able to describe
attraction but not explain it
humanity got closer however when Albert
Einstein introduced his general theory
of relativity Einstein thought a lot
about the fact that everything falls to
the ground at the same rate no matter
how massive something is when dropped it
will accelerate towards the earth down
gaining about 9.8 meters per second for
every second that it falls that means
that a hammer that's quite massive and a
not so massive feather when dropped from
the same height will hit the ground at
the same time okay what just happened
was in error in order to fall through
air a thing has to push air out of the
way but if it has a large surface area
and a low weight force it will have a
lot of air to move but will be able to
move that air very quickly in a vacuum
things do fall at the same rate
regardless of mass this was famously
demonstrated by Apollo 15 commander
David Scott on the moon that's weird
right I mean if a more massive object is
pulled with a greater force shouldn't it
fall faster well Newton's explanation
was simple larger masses are attracted
with greater forces but will also
require more force to be accelerated the
same as a less massive thing something a
hundred times more massive might require
a hundred times the force but it will be
pulled by gravity 100 times more so
everything falls to earth at the same
rate what a fun coincidence right maybe
not
Einstein realized that there's another
way for things to appear to fall
together
of their masses imagine a feather and a
hammer floating in space in a room if
the room is suddenly accelerated up at
9.8 m/s^2
the feather and the hammer will hit the
floor at the same time furthermore
whether it's the room coming up to meet
them or gravity being suddenly switched
on
neither object will feel any force
pushing them there's no way to tell
which of these happened this is
Einstein's famous equivalence principle
he once admitted that his greatest
thought ever was that of a man falling
off of a roof while falling the man
would not feel any forces on him even
though he's speeding up freefall is
indistinguishable from floating alone in
space from having no forces on you from
not being moved what if gravity isn't a
force at all what if things fall not
because they're being pushed or pulled
but because they're not being pushed or
pulled to see how this could be we need
to talk about straight lines what I have
here is a retractable ID badge holder
this is a great way to test for straight
paths because the string is always kept
taut the card I have behind has two
lines drawn on it and if while I pull
the string out it always stays between
those two lines I will know that I never
turned while I pulled it because any
turn will translate into a different
angle between the lines on the card and
the string now if I put two of these on
a flat table and pull them out always
ensuring that they go straight ahead
they will never meet they will be
forever parallel but now let's put them
on a sphere a curved surface again I
pull both strings forward making sure
that they always are pulled out straight
no turning wait they came together
well they didn't turn look maybe there's
some kind of weird force that pulled my
hands together and just like gravity I
didn't feel it but it happened no what
happened was not the result of a force
it was just a natural result of
curvature you might be thinking wait a
second are those really straight lines I
mean they don't look that straight to me
Oh also what if they've just moved along
latitude lines then they'd never come
together and those look pretty darn
straight but they're not a straight line
never turns and although latitude lines
look straight at first glance following
one requires turning to find straight
line paths on surfaces whether they're
flat like this or curved
I love the ribbon test now you can use
an actual ribbon but I have found that a
strip of paper works even better let's
take a look at this path right here it's
straight at first but then it curves now
if two people are traveling along this
curve and they want to stay together the
person on the inside will have to cover
a shorter distance than the person on
the outside since both sides of this
strip of paper cannot change their
lengths they'll help us find a straight
path
if the strip of paper can lay flat we'll
know that we have found a straight line
and as you can see the strip can lay
flat and follow the straight part of
this path but when it comes to the curve
in order to follow the path now the
strip well it has too much material on
the inside and that material bunches up
and leaves the plane therefore we know
that this part of the path is not
straight
let's use the ribbon test to find
straight lines on the surface of a cone
well from the looks of it aligned
directly from the base to the tip seems
like it would be straight and sure
enough yeah
the ribbon lays flat on that path but
what about a ring around the cone nope
doesn't work shorter distances around
nearer the tip of the cone mean that
there's too much ribbon up at the top so
it doesn't lay flat let's see what else
is there though besides this well if I
start here and just allow the ribbon to
lay flat huh I get a little curvy
looking shape like this I say curvy
looking because while to someone say at
the base this path might seem to go up
slow down change direction and then fall
down faster and faster since a ribbon on
such a path is flat it's actually for
inhabitants on the cones surface
perfectly straight if we trace the
ribbons path on to the cone we can see
this clearly because a cone can be
flattened a straight line on a curved
surface is called a geodesic here is a
geodesic on a sphere the Equator is one
here's another a line of latitude is not
a geodesic it's not a straight line to
see why let's try to follow it with the
ribbon you know what I have to keep kind
of lifting it yeah see distances around
the sphere becomes shorter as we go up
so there's too much material on the
ribbon up here and it leaves the surface
this path contains turns and in order to
turn a force has to act on you if no
forces did this is the path you would
take notice that the ribbon begins
moving due east
but then falls south
Falls Einstein realized that curvature
could cause things to be seemingly
attracted to one another without needing
to invent the existence of forces like
gravity but attraction only happens if
things move along the surface if they
stay still they well they don't come
together so for something at rest
how does falling begin I mean the thing
has to move in this direction but it's
at rest right
well yes but it's only at rest in space
and that's not the whole story
up down forward backward and left-right
are all you need to describe where an
event occur but a complete description
will also need to describe when together
these four dimensions formed a setting
in which everything in our universe
happens space-time since we can talk
about a falling pencil using just one
spatial dimension up and down we can use
a piece of paper to model space-time for
it okay so we've got up and down but we
have to add another direction the pencil
moves in time now if no forces act on
the pencil it won't move through space
it will only get older and as you can
see if all it does is get older it won't
fall if space-time was flat when I let
go of the pencil it wouldn't go anywhere
but now let's allow the earth which is
massive to manipulate space-time into
say a cone now with no forces acting on
it every part of the pencil follows a
straight line but on a cone as we saw
earlier such a path will look like this
it will fall this is because distances
around the cone are shorter higher up
time runs faster further from a massive
object but to go straight not turn every
part of the pencil must cover an equal
distance in space-time like this
only when the pencil hits the earth does
the repulsion of their mutual electrons
provide a force pushing the pencil off a
geodesic for the earth time is a series
of slices
from this evolution the pencils
force-free geodesic is why it falls not
a push or pull just the pencils natural
tendency to follow a straight line until
something acts on it now we only used
one dimension of space and one of time
because visualizing our two universes
three of space and one of time would
take us beyond the limits of what could
be shown on paper or screens but math
can take us there general relativity
allows us to calculate how much mass and
energy curved space-time and has been
used to explain things that Newton's
older theory of falling as the result of
forces couldn't like anomalies in the
orbit of mercury which orbits nearest
the Sun and is therefore most affected
by the sun's grip on space-time many
other experiments have confirmed general
relativity's picture of the universe
fitting the conclusion that there is no
gravity
there's just space-time its curvature
and a senate as John Wheeler famously
put it space-time grips mass telling it
how to move mass grips space-time
telling it how to curve relative to the
earth we don't move very fast even jet
airplanes move negligibly close to the
speed of light so relative to earth we
move almost exclusively through time as
such we are more affected by the way
time is curved by mass than how space is
curved this has led many to claim that
for the most part you feel as though
you're being pushed into the ground not
because of a force called gravity but
because time is moving faster for your
head than for your feet down is relative
and always changing but it exists
because of and is always in the
direction of slower time Bertrand
Russell called this the law of cosmic
laziness everything is naturally steered
towards where time is slowest we call
this falling going
so you don't have to keep anything on
the down-low
time will take care of that for you and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]
remember that you can support Vsauce and
Alzheimer's research by subscribing to
the Vsauce curiosity box the current one
comes with a code to get a free copy of
universe sandbox 2 which is amazing and
a whole host of other science toys and
tools picked by myself Jake and Kevin I
love it all so I hope to see you at
brain candy live we are coming to many
many cities very soon
hopefully one near you by going to the
show you can see Adam and I doing things
that will you may not have seen us do
before we also explore the science and
common misconceptions behind all things
err maybe I've said too much maybe not I
hope to see you there and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]